-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
and correspondent
on "The Daily Show."
She also stars in
"The Great North,"
which airs Sunday nights on Fox.
Let's take a look.
-Also I'd really love
for him to stay.
I mean, even though
I love your family,
it'd be great to have
someone from my family around.
[ Sighs ]
But it would be selfish of m
to let him go down
the wrong path again.
-Well, what if we test it out?
Huh? We could show Jerry
a typical day in Alaska
and see how he likes it.
-Yeah, if he enjoys
a rigorous Alaskan workday
then maybe this is
the place for him.
-Totally. Hey, we really nee
to get our heads out of here
now, because I am definitely
about to fart,
and it's not going
to smell like toffee.
-Ditto, babe.
[ Fart ]
Was that me or you?
-It was us, my love.
-Please welcome to the sho
Dulce Sloan.
♪♪♪♪
-Hello...
y'all!
-Wave like it's sold out.
-Hello.
-Yeah!
-Happy to be here. Yes.
-Standing room only.
-She came through.
Hello --
-Welcome!
-Hello, friend.
-How are you, Dulce?
Thank you so much
for being here in-person.
-Thank you for having me!
I'm so excited!
-It was so lovely to see you
the animated version of you --
-Yes.
-In bed with
the animated version
of my friend Will Forte --
-Yes.
-Who is someone who I have known
to talk a great deal about
farting in bed or out of bed
And so it was very --
an appropriate clip.
-Listen, I am someone who --
Honestly, I feel like
that women will finally be fre
when we can just fart
openly in public.
That's really -- I've been
trying to talk to the girl
who are trying to handle
this feminism,
and they don't really --
They're like, "But equal pay."
And I'm like,
"But farting in public!
No?" No one wants to help me
-Now's the time
to get it started.
We're all wearing masks anyway
Right?
-I said you can't smell it i
you got a good enough mask on.
-Hey, I want to ask about
your character on the show
because you actually -- They
allowed you to give some input
on the look of your character.
Was that -- Was that fun?
-Yes. So, Wendy Molyneux, who'
one of the creators of the show,
her and her sister Lizzie,
we were recording the pilot,
and they hadn't finished
with the design yet,
and they asked me
what she should look like.
And so, originally, her hair
was, like, a little straight
with a curl on the bottom. I was
like, "Just give her an afro!"
And they're like "Really?" I
said -- "Well, how would we --
I was like, "Squiggle.
Just do a squiggle.
Give her an afro.
And it'll be great."
And they were like,
"Okay, let's just see."
And then I didn't know
that she was going to have
a flower in her hair till we did
like the first big table read.
And I walk in,
I see the standee.
And I was like, "That's --
That's me!"
So it's -- I love
every time I see her
'cause it's like it's kind o
a piece of me is in her.
-It's wonderful.
The show takes place in Alaska
Have you crossed paths
with any actual Alaskans?
And how do they feel
about the show so far?
-I do have a friend,
a comic who grew up in Alaska,
and she thinks it's great.
People message me all the time
DM me, and they're like,
"Oh, you call them snow machines
instead of snowmobiles?
You guys are getting it right.
So, I mean, I've been to Alaska,
but it wasn't really cold.
And I was like,
"This is a wild place."
So, it's a lot for me.
But I'm glad
that people that are from ther
are enjoying the show.
-You're doing this -- You're
recording this show from home.
You're doing "The Daily Show
from home.
-Yes.
-I heard you just moved as well.
Was that out of necessity
because of your busy
work from home schedule?
-Absolutely. Because
I had a one-bedroom in --
'Cause I live in Queens.
It was a good size apartment
for New York.
And I was recording the cartoo
in my bedroom,
and I was doing "Daily Show"
in my living room.
And I would just walk in and go,
"I can't look at another
green screen in my living room."
So I went and got
another apartment.
And I just moved like last week.
-That's great. And does it -
Has it made
a huge difference already
insofar as it's nice
to not have your green scree
in the center of things?
-Huge difference.
And it wasn't a huge move
'cause I only moved
like a mile down the road.
So I was like, "I'm not read
for too many moves,
but this I can do."
But you know, now I've got
a bedroom that I can record in
as opposed to having my whol
house become an office.
And I've got all these
nice big windows,
and I have outdoor space.
So, it's just been --
I'm just waking up and I'm like,
"Oh, that's what
the sun looks like!
You're not supposed
to look out your window
and look at another building!"
The city is trash.
-[ Laughs ]
-Um...
So, yeah, it's been really great
to just not be on the firs
floor of a building.
-Oh, wow. You're not --
You're a little higher?
-She's on the sixth floor
waving at Jesus.
That's where I am.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I was looking
at other apartments,
and they were like in Manhattan.
It was like the 33rd floor
and the 40th floor
and the 50th floor
with a balcony.
And my mother's like,
"You can't live up there."
I was like, "Why not?"
She says, "Girl, if the wind
blows,
Jesus just pick you straight up.
You never hit the ground."
[ Laughter ]
-That's very good advice
that you'll hardly ever hear
from real estate professionals
-I mean, no, they not saved.
You're never going to hear
that kind of advice.
-Did you -- What did you learn
is there anything you learne
about yourself
from this past year
where I feel like we've had al
some time to be self-reflective?
-Uh...
If you're by yourself
for too long,
you don't technically
have to wear drawers.
Um, but you've just got to
be careful when you sneeze
so you don't mess up your couch.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Bras are necessary,
because I do feel like
that my titties have just kind
of been like, "And we're done.
Like, they kind of just like
give a sigh -- You know?
'Cause I've had them since
the Clinton administration
but I'm 37. Do that math.
So --
But I've learned that I need
to be around other people,
'cause I bumped into
my coffee table
during the lockdown
and said, "Excuse me"
and was waiting
for it to respond.
Um, and I was like, "Oh,
this coffee table's rude."
And it was like, "Man,
this is inanimate.
You need some help."
And the best thing I've learne
is that New Yorkers
have known the entire time
they were standing
too close to people.
-Ah.
-They just needed
stickers on the ground
to be like, "Hey,
you was rude the whole time!
[ Laughter ]
'Cause before, you'd be like
"Sir, you're too close to me."
He's like, "What of it?"
I was like, "Yo, man,
I'll hit you in the throat."
But now it's, "Sir,
you're too close to me."
"Oh, I'm sorry. I don't --
I was like -- Ah,
it's a blessing honestly.
-You're right.
I didn't think about that,
but I kind of hope
the 6 feet stickers stay
long after COVID is an issue
-We need it.
-Yeah.
-Think about how many people
were breathing on you.
-Yeah. It was really -- Lookin
back, it was pretty gross.
How are you on the tech
side of things,
getting it set up
in the early days
when you guys had to figure ou
how to film from home?
-Listen, I had to learn
how to balance things.
I got a box of grits
I'm trying to get into the union
because that's what I was
stacking things on.
-Sure.
-I don't know if he's
a grip, a key grip.
I don't know what his position
is, but I need y'all to help me,
'cause this box of grits was
working real hard in lockdown.
But that's what -- I've had to
learn all of the technicalities,
hooking up the computer to
the phone, to the teleprompter
to the -- I know too much.
It's not my job.
Like, I appreciated
the crew beforehand,
but now if I -- If -- [ Sighs
[ Voice breaking ]
When we can go back,
I'm kissing all the crew
on the mouth. You understand
I'm kissing all of them
on the mouth!
Call your wife.
Call your husband.
I don't care. We smooching
-That's very nice for you
to give them the heads-up.
And thank you so much
for making the trip.
It's just lovely
to have you here in person
-Thank you so much!
Glad to be here!
-"The Daily Show" airs
weeknights on Comedy Central
and "The Great North"
airs Sunday nights on Fox.